>> Jesse: AMERICA'S CRIME
CRISIS TURNING DEADLY FOR
POLICE, THREE PHILADELPHIA
S.W.A.T. OFFICERS WERE SHOT, TWO
CAN ADD IT HIT -- CONNECTICUT
OFFICERS KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY.
A THIRD OFFICER WAS WOUNDED,
THANKFULLY GOT DISCHARGE FROM
THE HOSPITAL THIS AFTERNOON.
THE COPS RESPONDING TO A 911
CALL FOR A POSSIBLE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCIDENT WHEN
THEY WERE MET WITH IMMEDIATE
GUNFIRE, THE SUSPECT WAS KILLED
DURING THE INITIAL SHOOT OUT,
THE FELLOW OFFICERS OVERCOME
WITH GRIEF.
>> WORDS CANNOT EXPRESS THE
SADNESS AND GRIEF THAT BRINGS ME
BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING.
THE ANSWER TO A CALL TO DUTY AND
RESPONDED WITHOUT HESITATION,
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY DID EVERY
NIGHT BEFORE THAT, AND THAT'S
WHAT ALL OF OUR OFFICERS DO AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO DAY AFTER
DAY.
TO OUR FALLEN OFFICERS FAMILIES,
WE WILL NEVER FORGET THE
SACRIFICE YOUR LOVED ONES HAVE
MADE.
WE ARE HERE FOR YOU, AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE HERE FOR YOU.
>> Jesse: SINCE MONDAY AT
LEAST 12 POLICE OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN SHOT.
SINCE MONDAY.
THE NATIONAL FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE SLAMMING THE CULTURE OF
LAWLESSNESS CREATED BY
ANTI-POLICE TO RHETORIC AND SOFT
ON CRIME.
THAT HAS TO BE A POLICEMAN, OR
WOMEN'S GREATEST FEAR TO BE
LURED INTO AN AMBUSH STYLE
ATTACK.
>> Judge Jeanine: ESPECIALLY
NOW, IT'S MORE AND MORE NOW.
AS HE WAS TALKING, AS THE
CHEAPEST TALKING I CANNOT HELP
BUT THINK OF ALL OF THE POLICE
OFFICERS FUNERALS THAT I HAVE
BEEN TO AND HOW THEIR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
COME FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
TO PAY THEIR RESPECTS.
I MEAN, WHAT HAS HAPPEN IN OUR
CULTURE IS THAT THERE IS NO FEAR
ON THE PART OF CRIMINALS TO KILL
POLICE.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THEY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT IT.
THEY WERE WORRIED ABOUT THE
DEATH PENALTY, NOW IT'S LIKE
THEY ARE JUST EMBOLDEN TO DO IT.
AND THE SADDEST PART IS YOU LOOK
AT THESE THREE GUYS WHO WERE
SHOT AND CONNECTICUT, TWO DEAD
IN THE PRIME OF THEIR LIVES AT
35-YEAR-OLD, 34-YEAR-OLD THAT
SAY GOODBYE TO THEIR SPOUSES.
ONE HAS TWO LITTLE KIDS AND HIS
WIFE IS PREGNANT AND NEVER TO
COME HOME AGAIN.
THEY DID NOT KNOW IT WAS THEIR
LAST DAY.
THE TWO DIRTBAGS DECIDE THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE IT A
DISMISSED STATE COULD DISPUTE
AND WAIT FOR THEM TO SHOW UP,
KILL THEM AND KILLED A TWO UP
THEM, ONE DIED IN THE HOSPITAL,
ONE AT THE SCENE AND THEN
SEVERELY INJURED THE THIRD ONE.
THIS IS JUST HAPPENING FAR TOO
OFTEN, AND I THINK THAT WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN NOW IS THAT WE
HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
STATUTES AS THEY RELATE TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, BECAUSE THEY
ARE IN THE LINE OF FIRE, THE
STATUTES AND THE PENALTIES HAS
TO BE INCREASED.
IF YOU ARE AGAINST THE DEATH
PENALTY, BE AGAINST THE DEATH
PENALTY, BUT IT HAS TO BE A LIFE
WITHOUT A POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE,
THERE HAS TO BE A DETERRENT NOW
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE CRIMINALS
WHO FEEL THAT SHOOTING A POLICE
OFFICER IS NOTHING THAT THEY
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT.
>> Jesse: AND THIS HAPPENED
NEAR ESPN'S HEADQUARTERS IN
BRISTOL, I HAVE DRIVEN BY THERE,
NOT NECESSARILY CONSIDERED A BAD
NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> Jessica: WHEN YOU SEE
BRISTOL CT COME UP ON THE
SCREEN, THAT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU
ARE USED TO SEEING WHATSOEVER
FOR THAT KIND OF PRESS
CONFERENCE, THAT WAS PART OF THE
SURPRISE AS WELL, AND SUDDENLY
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
SANDY HOOK, THESE ARE AREAS THAT
YOU DON'T THINK OF WHERE YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE THESE KINDS OF
TERRIBLE THINGS HAPPEN.
AND THERE WAS ANOTHER STORY OUT
OF PHILADELPHIA WHICH HAS HAD
ALL SORTS OF PROBLEMS WITH THIS
ISSUE AND I THOUGHT THAT THE
QUOTES FROM THE POLICE CHIEF
WERE REALLY IMPORTANT TO THIS.
SHE SAID IT IS NOT A JOB JOB OF
OFFICERS TO BE SHOT AT.
THAT IS NOT IN THE JOB
DESCRIPTION.
THEY PUT THEIR LIFE ON THE LINE,
BUT DON'T GO OUT EXPECTING THAT.
AND SAID THAT WE ARE TIRED OF
ARRESTING THE SAME SUSPECTS OVER
AND OVER.
A DIRECT SHOT AT D.A. CROSS AND
AS YOU CONTINUE TO SEE THESE
MEASURES BETWEEN POLICE CHIEFS
AND D.A.s, I THINK THAT THINGS
ARE GOING TO GET MORE MORE
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO NOT
CHANGE THEIR STANCES AND
CONSIDER THINGS LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, JUDGE, THAT YOU
HAVE TO UP THE PENALTIES OR
FRANKLY GO TO THE PEOPLE IN
POSITIONS OF POWER THAT HAVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO REMOVE
THESE TYPES OF PEOPLE THAT YOU
HAVE TO DO THAT TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE, BUT ALSO TO KEEP YOUR
VOTERS.
PEOPLE DON'T --
THE PEOPLE OF BRISTOL,
CONNECTICUT, THEY DON'T WANT TO
SEE THIS.
YOU DON'T MOVE TO BRISTOL,
CONNECTICUT, FOR THIS TO HAPPEN.
>> Jesse: IT IS INTERESTING,
DANA, JANUARY 6TH, TO BRING IT
BACK TO THAT, THAT WHEN POLICE
OFFICERS AND CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICERS WERE ASSAULTED, THERE
WAS THIS NATIONAL OUTRAGE AND
ESPECIALLY FROM THE DEMOCRATS,
YOU HEARD THAT THEY KEPT TALKING
ABOUT THE SUPPORT OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, NOW COPS ARE
BEING EXECUTED?
AND YOU DON'T HEAR THE SAME TYPE
OF OUTRAGE OR CONDEMNATION FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT ANY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THAT
COMES UNDER THAT KIND OF A
THREAT WHETHER ON JANUARY 6
STORY HERE IN BRISTOL,
CONNECTICUT, OR THE ONES WE TALK
ABOUT A NEW YORK OR THE ONES WE
TALK ABOUT IN TEXAS TWO WEEKS
AGO, THIS IS HAPPENING, IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE WHEN YOU SAID 12
SINCE MONDAY, IT'S ONLY
THURSDAY.
AND AMERICA DESERVES A LOT
BETTER AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
DESERVES A LOT BETTER FROM THEM.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU ARE
SEEING IS THAT CRIME IS TAKING
UP IN TERMS OF AN ISSUE AREA FOR
THESE MIDTERMS, AND PENNSYLVANIA
IS ONE, BUT PHILADELPHIA
OBVIOUSLY IS A TERRIBLE
SITUATION, BUT PLACES LIKE
BRISTOL, CONNECTICUT, SO IT
DEPENDS ON HOW YOUR VOTERS TURN
OUT, BUT I WANT TO POINT OUT
THIS ON THE MIDTERMS, IF YOU ARE
WATCHING SOME OF THE SENATE
RACES, WISCONSIN IS INCREDIBLE
WHAT HAPPEN, SO MANDELLA BARNES,
THE DEMOCRAT VOTED AGAINST THE
INCUMBENT RON JOHNSON, AND IN
AUGUST WAS UP IN THE POLLS AND
WAS LIKE, WOW, IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT RON JOHNSON COULD LOSE AND
THEN IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
RON JOHNSON AND REPUBLICAN
ALLIES CAME IN AND HAMMERED
MANDELA BARNES ON BEING
ANTI-POLICE, DEFUND THE POLICE,
HIS STANCES ON LAW ENFORCEMENT,
AND YESTERDAY A MAJOR POLL
SHOWED JOHNSON NOW COMFORTABLY
AHEAD BY SIX POINTS.
AND YOU MIGHT SEE THAT ANOTHER
RACES AS WELL, I JUST POINT THAT
ONE OUT TO SAY THAT I THINK THAT
PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION TO
THIS.
AND ANY DEMOCRAT THAT THINKS
THAT CRIME IS NOT A BIG DEAL I
THINK THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
PROVEN WRONG THIS YEAR.
>> Jesse: LAST WORD FOR GREG.
>> Greg: I'M GLAD THAT WE
COVER THIS, BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE
ANYBODY ELSE IS, BECAUSE IT JUST
PAYS TO REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
THE PRESS COVERAGE BETWEEN
POLICE MALFEASANCE OF THE LAST
WHATEVER FIVE YEARS, AND
OFFICERS GETTING KILLED
SOMETHING LIKE 50 OFFICERS
KILLED BY GUNFIRE THIS YEAR, ALL
RIGHT, IF THAT WERE ON A
CONSTANT LOOP THE WAY THAT ONE
ON ARM TO SUSPECT ON OTHER
NETWORKS, MAYBE THIS WOULD NOT
HAPPEN.
BOTH THEY ARE BAD, BUT SOME
REASON THE MEDIA AND YOU ALLUDED
TO THIS THE ONE THING IS FAR
WORSE THAN THE OTHER EVEN THOUGH
THE NUMBERS REFUTE THAT.
WHAT DOES IT TAKE FOR ESPN, ESPN
AND EXTREMELY WOKE COMPANY, WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE FOR THEM TO ADMIT
THAT THESE SO-CALLED
EXPERIMENTS, ACTUALLY THEY ARE
EXPERIMENTS, SO-CALLED REFORM
THAT IS TURNED OUT TO BE FIELD
GRIZZLY EXPERIMENTS HAVE TAKEN
THOUSANDS OF LIVES, THESE LIVES
ARE MINORITIES, THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE PROGRESSIVES CLAIM TO BE
HELPING, BUT INSTEAD BECAUSE OF
THEIR ASSUMPTION THAT THE POOR
ARE SOMEHOW OKAY WITH CRIMINALS.
EVEN THOUGH THE CRIMINALS ARE IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD, THEY ARE IN
EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD, BUT THEY ARE
IN THERE TOO, THAT SOMEHOW THEY
WOULD OBJECT TO HAVING A POLICE
PRESENCE, AND LAST, THIS IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE, MAY BE A LESSON
ABOUT WAITING UNTIL IT IS
POLITICALLY CONSEQUENTIAL TO
ACT.
IF YOU HAD ACTED WHEN PEOPLE
WERE RAISING THE ALARM, WHEN THE
CANARIES IN THE COAL MINE WERE
SCREAMING, YOU MIGHT NOT BE
BEHIND IN THESE RACES, BUT IT IS
THAT YOU WAITED UNTIL IT WAS
POLITICALLY CONSEQUENTIAL AND
NOW YOU WI